- The magic happens when
we're all on the same page
collaborating and building
something together.
There's always this
temptation to assume that
the way things are today is
the way things are going to be.
We're always sort of experimenting.
The International itself
was an experiment.
Approach the problem of,
if I'm a fan and I hear about this,
it gets me really fired up and excited.
The rate of innovation is
not remaining constant.
It's not like we're plateauing.
In just about every dimension,
innovation is increasing.
We thrive on the feedback we receive.
We get better when we
know what people think,
both positive and negative.
If you have a limited amount of time,
that's the scarcest resource we have.
There wasn't some magic pioneer fairy
who hit us on the head and
allowed us to do pioneering work.
But, that's how we evolve.
Usually, by people deciding
that I have a bad idea.
(laughing)
- He's the co-founder
and managing director
of the video game company Valve.
He spent 13 years working for Microsoft.
Ultimately, becoming a
Microsoft millionaire.
According to Forbes Magazine,
he has a net worth of 2.2 billion dollars.
He's Gabe Newell and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(explosion)
- You're testing your ideas,
you're stimulating each other.
That's what makes us successful.
It's not some flash of
brilliance by somebody
who then codes 24 hours a day for 3 weeks.
The magic happens when
we're all on the same page
collaborating and building
something together.
There's always this
temptation to assume that
the way things are today is
the way things are going to be
and having been through this long enough,
in the games industry,
I think I, and everyone
at Valve, know that
you're only as successful
as what you've done lately.
So, the idea that Steam
is somehow the anything,
the answer to digital distribution,
I think ignores the fact
that every two or three years
something is going to change dramatically.
It's like, along comes the Wii
and that overthrows a bunch of ideas.
Along comes social gaming
and that throws over
a bunch of ideas about
what things are like.
You know, I think Steam is the same way.
It's like, if you stand still
and if you're not looking
to the future and doing
the things that you need to
to be valuable in the future
to customers and partners,
you're going to get left
behind really rapidly.
So, that's what we focus in on,
is what do we need to do next.
What are the tools and
services and features
and capabilities to make gamers happy
and other software developers happy.
We look at all of our games
and evaluate them in terms of
what we think would be
best for the community.
You know, we're always
sort of experimenting.
The International itself
was an experiment.
You know, Counter Strike was an experiment
all the way back at the beginning
where we were like, maybe we
can do an online only game.
So, we're always sort
of looking for each game
will sort of leap frog the other.
Then what we learn goes back
to all of our other games.
- [Interviewer] Of course,
your first game was Half Life,
which was very successful.
What was the key to that?
- I think part of the reason
that the community responded to it
is we approached the game like fans.
We wanted to ... It seemed like
people were looking at what
id had been creating with Doom and Quake
and had picked out some of
the least interesting details
of those games to build upon.
If a double-barrelled shotgun was good,
a four-barrelled shotgun was better
and what we had thought when
we were playing the game was,
there was so much atmosphere
and so much environmental story telling
that was going on in these games
that they sort of opened
the door to this new way,
this new kind of entertainment,
and that viewing it as
just a shooting gallery,
which is what all of the Doom copies and,
later, Quake copies
seemed to be extracting
from the success of Doom and Quake,
was missing the whole
point of what we as fans
had seen that had gotten
us really excited.
And so, that's what the
impulse was behind our games,
was to take those pieces as fans
that we had really loved about those games
and try to amplify that and build on that
as much as we could.
I think it turned out that
we were on the right track,
that approaching it that
way with sort of a fan's
enthusiasm and sensibilities
about what was compelling about
and what the opportunities
were to push even further.
That ended up really working in our favor
and I think that that
trying to think like a fan
is a super valuable thing
to any game developer.
Don't think about it in terms
of constraints, or budgets,
or what management somewhere is thinking,
but approach the problem of, if I'm a fan
and I hear about this,
it gets me really fired up and excited.
That's a valuable tool in
approaching this business.
I get a lot of questions from other
people who run companies
about organizations.
I think that if the important
thing that you do is about
measure-ability and repeatability,
then hierarchical
organizations are appropriate,
but that's not what is
happening in our industry.
The rate of innovation is
not remaining constant.
It's not like we're plateauing.
In just about every dimension,
innovation is increasing
and the most effective organizations
are those that can self-organize
and that are extremely flat.
And that the question, when
you're trying to think about
how your company is organized
or how you want it to grow,
is how you can help people deliver,
smart and creative people
create the most value
and delivered as efficiently
as possible to your customers.
The decision to break into episodes
wasn't really driven by
the story requirements.
The story sort of ended
being fit into three buckets.
Typically, in any of these larger arcs,
it's not too surprising
that you can think of them as three acts
and that's a very
traditional Hollywood-esque
approach to story telling.
The decision to go with
episodics was more driven out of
the experience we had
working on Half Life 2,
where we really weren't
able to give anything
to our customers for
like a five year period.
And, that was very hard
on us as game developers
because we thrive on
the feedback we receive.
We get better when we
know what people think,
both positive and negative
and so with episodic,
it really allowed us to
tighten that loop up enormously.
There are lots of benefits
in terms of managing scale,
in terms of reacting to what's happening
on the hardware side,
but one of the biggest reasons is simply
so we don't get into a situation
where we have to wait five
years before hearing from
the people who play our games about
what worked and what we need to do better.
If you have a limited amount of time,
that's the scarcest resource we have,
every decision you make with your time
is a vote about what the
company's priority should be.
So the question you should
ask as a programmer is:
What's the best way for me
to spend my time right now
that creates value for our customer.
There wasn't some magic pioneer fairy
who hit us on the head and
allowed us to do pioneering work.
It's really a consequence of
a bunch of other decisions
you make along the way.
How your games are being funded,
how you select your colleagues,
how you organize your teams,
are really the things that
are going to allow you
to do pioneering work.
In our case, we've designed
the company in such a way
that we really, not only
give everyone who works there
the opportunity, but they
all have the expectation
that they're going to be doing
original and creative work.
I am a big believer in
one person, one office.
DeMarco's Peopleware, if
anybody has read that,
I sort of treat that as a bible.
And so I was like, I hated cubicles
with a passion and a vengeance.
It's like, they grew out of
this data general philosophy,
of if you're screwing your employees,
you're probably doing something right.
So, I was like, okay, everybody
always has their own office.
And, you know, you've got a
do not disturb button on your phone
and you have a door you can close
and you can decorate your
office however you want
and people kept sneaking
into other people's offices
and then they started tearing doors down.
So, everybody had their own office,
but nobody was ever in it.
So, they were all congregating
in our conference rooms
and so we had all these empty offices
and all these clusters of
people in conference rooms
and that's when I realized, you know,
they were making the right decision.
They were deciding that
there were benefits to being
in closer proximity to other people
and that Gabe's rigid adherence
to one person, one office
was actually hurting their productivity.
So, even after being hit
on the head long enough,
I realized that everybody
else was making a decision
that was correct for them
and so now we just say
everybody designs their own office space.
So, our largest single room, right now,
has about 80 people in it.
I share an office with two other people.
That's one of the things you think about.
You think about how you
communicate with other people.
You think about what's an
optimal work environment
for the goals that you have.
Desks are all on wheels.
We only have two contact
points with the floor.
So, you can pack up and join
a different group of people
in about 15 minutes.
Some people are working on the design of,
if anybody's done paired programming,
there are some people who
are trying to build a desk
that's more optimal for paired programming
and giving you a shared thing.
And, they have to make a
decision whether it's more worth
their time to work on something like that
than it is to do the work
that they already are.
So, we just sort of said, okay,
each person has to make
their own decisions about
what they work, who they're working with,
what are the tools they need,
and what their offices ought to look like.
But, that's how we evolve.
Usually, by people deciding
that I have a bad idea.
- And this wonderful mask.
(crowd talking)
Alright, thanks Gabe.
- Thanks.
- Can I get a picture of you as well.
- Sure.
- [Audience Member] Put on the mask.
- I'll put on the mask.
- Alright.
(laughing)
- [Audience] Three, three, three, three.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Kinaru Helio asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Gabe Newell's
top 10 rules meant the most to you,
had the biggest impact on your life.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(explosion)